we got to get back to bianca because
this has been a big month for love and
for weddings today another very popular
day and that bianca is all dressed for
the part to stand at the altar and we're
sorry we couldn't hear you earlier but
bianca tell us more about all the
weddings going on downtown and are you
one of them
yes i do sherry i'm just waiting on the
groom
i mean he should be here soon right
fingers crossed but this is a huge day
for so many people our city has already
reached the 5 millionth wedding this
past weekend and here i'm joined by
rachel snead of lucky little wedding
chapel in downtown so tell me on a
normal tuesday you do about 30 max
weddings but on this tuesday how many do
you have we're going to do over hundred
i'm sure
and you're one of the few chapels that
still have the wedding dresses right yes
absolutely so it's wonderful because we
can have couples come in right off the
street they just got their license
they're excited they want to do this
they walk in they see the gowns and
tuxedos and we can fit them and get them
hair and makeup ready and get them
married and on to celebrating yeah and
this was a big day a lot of people
booked this in advance so tell me what
was some of the prep that you all did to
prepare for this big day we began to see
the trend about six months ago that a
lot of people were booking so we
actually reached out to the city
recently and uh got permitted for a
couple of pop-up areas to accommodate
the volume that we were expecting so and
then just a lot of admin prep just
making sure we're not missing any of the
details you know custom songs the flower
choices and stuff like that so and again
yeah because you're doing so many at a
high volume throughout the day how are
you making each one special
uh we're just taking our time you know
with each one and we have a lot of staff
so the couple's going to not feel rushed
because they're you know while one
photographer is with one couple they
have another one joining the next couple
so yeah all right so we're looking
forward to it they got more weddings
starting up at 8 a.m they started at
midnight tonight they took a break just
for us and so they're gonna go all the
way until midnight tonight of people
getting married on this lucky day and um
yeah i'm one of them i'm gonna own it in
my mind okay back to you guys in the
studio
well bianca there are so many guys out
there who would be so lucky to have you
so come on guys step up don't leave the
bride hanging at the altar there good
luck